التقى وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكن
مع ولي العهد السعودي الأمير محمد بون
سلمان في جدة، ويقول مسؤولون أمريكيون إن
الاجتماع استمر أكثر من ساعة
وناقش الرجلان مجموعة من
القضايا الإقليمية والثنائية، ويعد هذا الاجتماع
أحدث خطوة نحو تبادل اللوم
بين البلدين.  في بلداننا بشأن
هذا، نريد أن نذهب إلى شبكة CNN ونيك
روبرتسون الموجود معنا من لندن
نقدر ذلك يا نيك خاصة نظرًا
لخبرتك الواسعة في تغطية هذا الأمر،
هل تشعر أنه بالإضافة إلى
إصلاح العلاقات،
قلنا للتو أن لينكولن لديه المزيد من الوضوح
الأهداف هنا ومن الواضح أننا يجب أن نلاحظ
أن أسعار النفط هي في مقدمة أولوياتنا، وقد
قررت المملكة العربية السعودية للتو في اليومين الماضيين أن
يجتمع أوبك بلس لخفض الإنتاج
بمقدار 10 حوالي مليون برميل من النفط
يوميًا، لذلك هذا  إنه
مهم للوزير بلينكوم
لأن هذا ينطوي على احتمال
رفع أسعار الغاز في
مضخات الغاز في الولايات المتحدة أه إنها
انتخابات العام المقبل وهذا ليس جيدًا
ولكن أيضًا أي زيادة في سعر
النفط تساعد روسيا في تمويل حربها  في أوكرانيا،
ستكون هذه قضية كبيرة كما تقول،
لكن القضايا الأخرى التي ستكون بالتأكيد مطروحة
على الطاولة ستكون تطبيع
العلاقات بين إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية،
وهو أمر
مهم بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة،
فضلاً عن نوع من المزيد  قطعة دائمة في
اليمن، سمعنا وزير الخارجية
يشكر السعوديين على دعمهم
ومساعدتهم في إخراج المواطنين الأمريكيين من
السودان، وهو مجال تعاون،
وهناك حديث أيضًا عن تحسين
العلاقات الاقتصادية، لذا هناك الكثير مما
يمكن أن نلمحه  حاول أن تضع يديه نوعًا ما
ولكن ليس من الواضح أنك
تعرف مقدار التعاون أه دون
دفع الثمن الذي
سيقدمه السعوديون مقابل أي من ذلك،
سيكون بالتأكيد صعبًا كما
قلت انتزاع أي من هؤلاء  أنواع
التنازلات، كما تعلم، كنا
نناقش الوضع مع حقوق الإنسان في لعبة الجولف
أو الوضع في المقدمة والوسط مع
إعلان PGA عن الاندماج مع لعبة الجولف الحية، كما
تعلمون، جو بايدن، علينا أن نلاحظ
كمرشح صرح بصراحة أنه
سيجعل السعوديين منبوذين، ومع ذلك  يومض
هناك إنه على حق نيك على الأرض
يحاول الآن تعزيز العلاقات
لماذا المحور الذي
تعرفه السعوديون توقعوا دائمًا أن
أه نباح بايدن سيكون أسوأ من
طعمه لكنهم لم يتوقعوا حقًا
أن تتدهور علاقاتهم كما
حدث  لقد عادت تلك العلاقات إلى
الوراء، إن وجود المملكة العربية السعودية هو جزء
من تلك الصورة ولكن أعتقد أنه
يمثل أيضًا ما رأيناه من
المملكة العربية السعودية وهو أنها تغير
موقعها وقوتها في
الأسواق العالمية كونها تلعب كرة القدم سواء كان ذلك
ممارسة لعبة الجولف في العديد من
المجالات المختلفة في الدبلوماسية، لذلك هناك ذلك ولكن
أيضًا العالم تغير كثيرًا منذ أن
تولى الرئيس بايدن منصبه
وواقعه هو أحلامه بنوع من
الديمقراطية العالمية الشاملة
والقدرة على الدفع نوعًا ما  إن وقوف منتهكي حقوق الإنسان
إلى جانب
النفوذ الدولي، وهذا ليس واقعاً، كان لا بد
من تغييره، وهو جزء من ذلك